i grew up in manhattan i grew up on the
west side
and around the dinner table i heard
stories and one of the stories was
that my parents were leaving berlin
they had a six-week visa to come to new
york to work
my father asked his mother for uh
jewelry
and he bought a box of chocolate melted
the chocolate down
and covered all of the pieces of jewelry
in chocolate put it in the box put the
box under his arm
so that when the nazis said are you
taking anything of value
out of germany he said no check my bags
check us nothing he then got to new york
city
and he pawned the jewelry
eventually started a lumber business and
was able to buy the jewelry back and
i have the pocket watch
from my great-grandfather
that was smuggled out of germany
uh encased in chocolate still works
um just an amazing
thing to have to pass down from
generation
to generation okay so same apartment
manhattan on every windowsill
was a spider plant the legend was
that the mother of these spider plants
came out in a coffin at the feet
of tanta and akulman
now i never really had real aunts and
uncles because they were all taken
i never had grandparents because they
were all
taken to the the camps but we did have
these plants now when i came in 1973
to california and i auditioned two weeks
in to my stay here
i auditioned for happy days and when i
got
the part when i when we were going to do
the pilot
and then all of a sudden we were picked
up came out here
to do the first season lived in l.a
and i brought with me a cutting from the
windowsill
of one of those spider plants and
this is the result so it's been growing
and as you can see
um you know it has all these babies
and then you plant these babies and
um i did so this plant
the mother of this plant came out of
germany
in a coffin at the feet
of anna cullman and uh then
i took babies and i put them in pots
so that each of my children have a baby
to plant in their garden to uh
continue the tradition
[Music]